thank you sure whatever Wow the beauty
of it is if you read Donnie Brasco the
first crime family he busted was the
Chicago crime family and their
counterpart was the Milwaukee crime
family and the big business was slot
machines cigarette machines all those
same machines
Donnie Brasco took them down they just
didn't talk about in the movie right so
the first time I went to Milwaukee
people like not brought him gold and he
go around the corner to Italian though
and knows his place in 1998 that
meatball heroes for two dollars it was a
mafia joint to the hill it's not like
cheese three little fat guys back there
take a book but man they just made
meatballs all day and put them on bread
the little butt so now I'm starting to
get wondering oh my god yeah Wallace and
[__] me both heroes in our face the
only thing we're gonna get meatball
heroes but we never get me but we know I
can never he saw about in the walking
start the goddamn sure you don't get
home before he will you and go back to
the gym she went to the agenda 20 years
old [__] around no no no read yet oh
sorry she showing I do it if the guy's
not review your sorry I must do this we
ready yeah well oh we've been going when
you let me Paul thing what you've been
going what the [__] is wrong with you
you need to tell me the podcast is
started the podcast is called lets you
try to tell me well guess what it's
Monday May 8 and church' what's happened
now is in the [__] house for
starters we want to give a shout out
what is me on these Oh just sorry
seriously soft feel good underwears
delivered right to your door so go ahead
and revamped the underwear drawer you
deserve it again this podcast is brought
to you by me undies calm right now go to
me undies calm / Joey me undies calm /
Joey and get 20% off your first pair
number two one of the best food
companies out there blue apron
number one with fresh ingredients and
recipe delivery service in the country
they deliver fresh seasonal food right
to your door and you cook it in 30
minutes or less check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals free
free shipping by going to blue apron
calm / Joey again blue apron calm / Joey
and I want to welcome a company to the
church that is one of the best companies
out there because you don't have to
leave the house and I'm talking about
Stan's comm these days you can get
practically everything on demand like
our podcasts listen whenever you want
and when it's convenient to you why go
to the post office to stand on line and
get breathed on by the bunch of people
forget that go to stamps.com
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Joey that
steps calm and - Joey and I'm going to
give you a four week trial includes
postage and a digital scale that's how
I'm rolling on the church or what's
happening now yeah kick that mule Lee oh
[__]
when it couldn't get any better upstairs
that Eric [__] yes this is great lewd
music right here you put the you put the
music on you eat the quail ooh you gave
the girl the gorilla biscuit by the end
of the song you both naked and she's
telling you she's got a place for twenty
others
here we go Monday May 8 the Churchill
was happening now it's good what would
you say what's happening you beautiful
[__] welcome to podcast ville
uncle Joey here the Church of what's
happening now my main man in studio Matt
full charge full tron what's up and my
little brother who is [__] up tonight
of some of the best weed I've gotten all
year my main man mr. Lisa at I don't
know where you get bottles with no label
I think that need to know huh I get a
call a voice they hang up on me I'm
coming in that dress I show up I give an
envelope they give me an envelope I
don't ask questions that's a beauty by
Joey Diaz why I ask questions I don't
care who raised don't care what you put
in it as long as I see the devil for 10
minutes I'm good I care about I care
when we get in are you going to I
wouldn't [__] you go we're here let's
get a man sitting behind you sitting
behind [__] Led Zeppelin - as Sabbath
bloody Sabbath what the [__] are you
going no I guess gee thank you for
watching uh support me on various
doughnuts
congratulation client it was ass [__]
spoon deal my genius I'm probably friend
of a friend of a friend of a friend
that's what happens when you live here
for 20 years every once in a while one
day you do something you don't really
want to do it doesn't pay you a lot of
money but you committed to it and you do
it and something good comes to you one
day and a little while somebody calls
you with a job and you're like really
man
thank you and people call you with jobs
all the time but some jobs are bigger
sometimes people call you money they
work three days on a YouTube project for
three days for free you know I'm saying
yeah so you take those and you take
everything that comes at you and
eventually somebody calls you with a
[__] job there you go Jesus Christ is
a [__] job yeah it's mine that I
still had audition but it was mine to
lose right you're I'm saying the various
bills yeah now I know you have an agent
but are there like are there like acting
gigs online like how you apply to jobs
online
just submit yourself 17 years ago when
actors access around there
I would pay the 69 dollars a year and
I'd have my wife scan my headshots three
or four headshots and I'd sit there
every night and look through jobs can I
tell you what I booked on there you
ready ready cold case first step to the
first year I got in cold case yeah and I
booked a guest star off show facts
I booked Law & Order SVU damn from show
facts
I booked a movie which I got fired from
in Jamaica I show facts so I used to
hustle on show facts when you get fire
in Jamaica this is tough to get the
plane ticket back or you know the play
was a round-trip ticket
okay I was around trip eken it was one
of those [__] they paid for it with
miles
so you're the last one to get on the
plane yeah you're the last one to get
your luggage and your [__] luggage is
wet like it was one of those [__]
deals right I don't land in Miami and
wait for 10 hours for a connecting
flight you know it was one of those day
right so I got myself out of it real
quick but uh I said to up suing him yeah
[__] yeah and I settled out of court
because I did the paperwork and the
Screen Actors Guild was supposed to
represent you sue them for the money
they owed me which was two weeks of work
was right out of money right to point I
did the movie the movie was going to be
a disaster
mm-hmm I knew this going in but it was I
would get paid before Christmas yeah my
wife would get a it was way before I was
married she get her the president we get
a few lobster tails worth a heat at the
house you know so I meant the world to
me I get a job when I got fine I still
put it together but I tried too soon I
think it was two weeks of 1,200 a week
so I assumed for 2,400 bucks yeah all
right I'm waiting for my 24 hunting for
this for small 24 for years finally I
bump into somebody and I tell him the
story is a gret and they tell me to call
him on Monday and I call him he looks
into it he goes you know what am pager
because sag build them for 10,000
Oh sag testin I want $400 charge for
this 2004 firing them because it was his
fault so he was getting sued by SEC okay
I had a clear case all right I was
strong case yeah it was the board so I
called the guy like again two weeks
before Christmas and I go he goes they
will let me release the movie and they
won't give me back my bond unless I
settle with you uh-huh
I know I'm not here to rob you just give
me what you owe me I gave my bank
account he told me be there in the
morning he put it in I dropped the clamp
nice and that was it only took a year
the movie never got released
not even I need to never saw the light
of day which I knew Club Paradise - yeah
it was just a [__] disaster what's
happening in your world beautiful me I'm
going on the road with you this week
this is going on with me you were on the
roads like nine [__] months I love to
mind you switch with Ari Ari moves back
in your showers I switch us to [__]
cats I switch with Ari Shaffir last year
which is cooler [__] I was great cool
this [__] he's such a great guy I'm
happy to have him back he sounds good
and you know yeah so when did he get
back in touch with everybody like what's
going on with that you know he called me
yeah he's my brother and he called me
and he goes listen this was going on and
he told me like a man mid-december
I had heard rumblings about it yeah but
I thought it was [__] and her
rumblings about it because we share the
same agent so it was [__] hon just
called [__] I ain't got I got a
friend and he called me he no longer
what I need to see the world honey yeah
varying stuff and write jokes and listen
if I was single I'd disappear out of
here and we said take leave go to Miami
for five [__] days and interview
people and yeah you told me about that
Nyack and it made me feel like like I
wanted to do that William like I just
felt great that like even he got to go
and do it like it was just such an
escape I was because I was so exhausted
from the road I was like aw somebody's
getting out of it for a little bit like
it's cool that's not a good to me yeah I
have this fantasy ever since we got lift
as a sponsor I had
this fantasy it was just like lifting
and driving across America well just
from city the city of the driver I've
done that I just done that and just
seeing the city seeing it like working
in a city and like getting to live there
for a couple weeks I don't know if you
could like financially like or for
hotels every night maybe you have to
find like someone else
crash with but so I'm like that's just
like it's not like a an aspiration of
mine looks like a fantasy I have some
Trey well you guys don't have anything
like that anything we've done so much
kinda you want me to tell you something
man
I love doing comic and if I had to get
to top three things I like about doing
Connelly what was the journey the other
woman's are people we don't meet a what
the other one was what's that I know
every nook and cranny in this [__]
country
you got homes away from home oh I've
been there clearly I don't remember a
lot of things right but I've been to
every nook and cranny remember when you
start Connor you work in hellos
yeah so I started in Denver so I would
[__] go to these towns that you never
even heard of yeah
my population in 2000 mm-hmm I knew
people who booked rooms and all those
type of towns yeah and you drive in and
see if they had a gas station a laundry
mat and a super mahogany post office the
police department was like two doors you
know like and you got how these people
live it's a different way of life we
were talking about triple runs the other
day which is run that you do when you
first start right and they really show
you the discipline of the road and how
it works and blah blah blah getting up
early and getting drunk how to survive
on $50 a night TSU a lot but the one
thing about triple ones is that he used
to have this room in Craig Colorado
he had like eight weeks of work potato
run one potato run - yeah Missoula run
one Missoula run - that means he had two
clubs in the same city
he read hustle David Tribune give them
to that I'm gonna go on a limb here I
wouldn't be here right now without David
shrivel because David Tribble was the
fundamentals of comic I learned it from
ducks my help but I heard yeah I'll
expand hope lives on a David Tribble
tour yeah I immediately want to
before you do it what is it doing right
and you learn a lot you learn how to
work yourself out of holes and those
wrote mm-hmm you know what it's like to
go to Idaho on Tuesday night to a room
when you get there and go oh it doesn't
say anything you can't curse these
Mormons in the room yeah
it's a Mormon bar and you have to switch
up your game you know switch up your
[__] a lot of bulls and [__] and then
I letting you call it unable to forty
five to nine then what you're in an hour
yeah it's great guys it's a discipline
then you got to get back to your hotel
so here you are a star in a city that is
[__] small and there's always a
waitress it's got drugs or a guy and his
girlfriend want to bring you over for
you to bang the girlfriend him to watch
I mean that's a big thing on Shiva right
there the weirdest situations triple
runs are filth that filth because when
you go to that city you're a beautiful
movie star that it's [__] crazy Lee
do you think those people go every week
yeah yeah that's the they have nothing
else to do on Wednesday night and it's
Friday night to have a live band
Saturday I have a live band and I'm not
putting that lifestyle down by anything
it sounds great but it's a complete
different lifestyle yeah and yeah I'm
not Johnny into that I can't take it
with you guys and talk about the Vatican
and Itoko can't talk to you guys about
going to Brazil into the jungles
ayahuasca but let me taste as a [__]
immigrant I really learned what this
country was about I go to all these
cities right I could tell you more about
the economy right now today from me
going to these cities
I learned that much and when I go to
Charlotte I see construction and Utah
this week I counted floor five [__]
cranes right you know in Salt Lake City
that's right looks like four cranes yeah
it looks a movement on the streets
there's a lot of cities you go to that
get quiet and every city has a
personality and I've got to seen all
those personalities yeah I'm really
happy about that Mesa
Snake River North Dakota I didn't get
high for five days on this dribble run
yeah what kind of high like an airliner
everyone smoking dope okay on the road
alright and shitty weed all throughout
[__] northern part of the country was
getting brown weed right and I finally
get to Snake River or one of those
Dakotas
on a Friday night and I'm hungry and
they go you get 50% off at the
restaurant downstairs the hotel so I get
to the hotel I'm about to pass out I
look on the back of this one lonely
Mexican in the kitchen that was my only
hope
ahh I made eye contact with him he came
over we started talking in Spanish I
asked him where the [__] was if he had a
cousin who sold coke yeah he goes I got
a cousin who sold bombs you know I'm
saying I got a cousin who sells this
[__] that can hablo Escobar he's like a
boss nephew he gave me a handful of blow
for like 40 bucks a trivet
you know he just learned all these crazy
things like people I went to towns where
people would go so what hotel you're
staying here right now I'm not I'm
asleep my car don't be foolish
staying on living room and you're like
what you know who I am I could Rob you
in the middle of that but from that love
it makes you a Buick was so cool when
you wake up and then made you breakfast
and they want to drive you to show you
where the Kmart is sitting buy new
t-shirts yeah it's really [__] crazy
it's really [__] crazy you see the
beauty of people you see the shittiness
of people I was a buffalo one time
standing there and the black guys
running at me I mean the [__]
McDonald's Egg McMuffin yeah I got the
potato Peck cake right I got the
coca-cola in those days it's summer of
98 it's winter of 98 this is like my
third time in Buffalo and I did
everything on a bus okay all my business
was done on a bus greyhound mm-hmm I
would fly the Manhattan base myself out
of Jersey and take buses Frank's Myrtle
Beach DC Philly [__] Buffalo Syracuse
I might have done that before now what
is the bus like a Florida that's a long
one that's like how I never took that
one I think it's close to 20 hours I
took a train from Miami to Myrtle Beach
South Carolina one of our talent
variances in my life never took a train
again wave they bang you on each [__]
level they're like [__] filthy
animals they're more expensive than
planes like it's not exactly that oh my
god they bang you at the station then
you get on and you got a chin what
happened to the room every movie you
watch it we've got a rule
they sleep in cycles are there be those
are there then you go in that costs more
money how much more 200 okay so now I'm
up to get a ticket with 6950 you jump it
up and down like I say because sometimes
you would work as a feature you get fall
on your brain I snorted 200 yeah I got
to watch you for the journey I can take
the flight for 189 and slide the nickel
got a shoplift order at the airport
yeah oh and I gotta get somebody to
drive me like a feature act or the emcee
I gotta give them a small nickel or
enjoy and then I subtract at the train
of 69 bucks I saved one hundred I get
there with the yardstick in my pocket
yeah I go out I buy a G bubble blow oh
my god they bug me I took the train
right [__] yet to to no no no I didn't
have coke for the train ride had like
two joints and I would get off and smoke
the joint and get back on the train
[__] up and put my little Walkman on
and yeah
these [__] you know I'm like I
want to eat and I gonna cost $24 a
minute costs $24 you gotta buy a whole
menu what if I just want a cup of
[__] noodle soup right that like
chicken noodle soup with a bunch of crap
is that'll fill you good for three huh
for the small $3 no they wanted 24 for
the whole [__] meal because you
probably went to like so that I've
rented it they have a first class and
then they have like a general boarding
it's crazy that I'm never even sat like
that in a restaurant I went to like the
food car that has microwave pizzas and
terrible food no no after that [__]
train was and I was getting off getting
stoned but the buses of the [__]
greyhounds is really the [__] grave
Greyhound is like traveling aboard
abroad when you get to the bus station
you don't know who you're gonna run into
you don't know who you're gonna sit next
to you got an idea yeah it's got to be
somebody who bug somebody has got to be
somebody who's on the loose
somebody's I need you to pay cash
somebody who you know Oh somebody money
for booking and leaving town right women
who will leave in their husbands because
I got hit the head with a bat the night
before and they got a [__] they got a
Swami hat on talking about like
prisoners at like who are like getting
released from jail on buses yeah you
have no [__] idea the adventures I've
had on buses I had so many adventures I
forgot not and I had listened you know
me I don't like traffic yeah I would
a bus from 97 to 2000 - yeah [__] it
I ride a bus track I heard a guy on a
bus like like he was he was fighting
that like capitalism was the best like
former government when clearly it just
had not worked out for him like
communism we work better for you dude
come on
though people neglect the buses it's
funny they have a bus station around the
corner here Magnolia and from time to
time pass by there at night and you'll
see creepy people
oh yeah the bus station that means you
have no money some people don't even
take the bus they just wanna sleep there
no that bus station you can't sleep
there no no no that [__] closes
at 6:00 okay
there is no future and there is nothing
but darkness and rats over there when I
slept with the bus drops you off at
11:00 but if you got money you can walk
half a block and go to no whole diner
right that's why I snowed on is
dangerous at night because his bus
people being lurking looking for a sign
recorder as above all free remember the
one night we were there we chew
cigarettes away and I got picked them up
and smoked him he was a bus creature
from mobile food with [__] crayons
done with it well you have the knife
like the homeless kid sat down next to
me or I think I might have been on the
phone with you whenever I'm in that
situation they come over like want to
borrow my phone he want me to lead drop
him off in a motel 6 and then 9
somewhere I always get approached for
that stuff it's [__] crazy the people
that come up i sat next to two homeless
guys on a plane one time this is a true
story like they were mules or something
they smell bad they were dirty as [__]
one guy tried to smoke on the plane like
they were insane they're [__]
homeless and then a week later I
actually saw the guy walking down Sunset
Boulevard I was like what's their
[__] story man how do they have money
to fly from Chicago to LA when they're
clearly [__] homeless a nose teeth or
anything maybe what the [__] they were
like they were running drugs or symbol
oh there's a thing here will they put
you on a plane and they put you on a bus
ticket to give you a bus ticket
oh really there's something here there's
a program because I heard about on the
news where something of your homeless
send you back to your just you do some
paperwork on your bus ticket out maybe
in Chicago they fly out first-class
these days are clearly homeless man I
think the one guy was sitting in my seat
I'm like you're in my seat man like I
separated the two of them and then ones
like I wouldn't sit there he's like I
just whacked feces all over the [__]
refer to you yes it's crazy
and Tosh is Daniel Tosh is on the other
side of me going I just laughing at me
for like the [__] bad luck I had and
you sent by the exit window he goes if I
open this up do you think we all die I'm
like yes like I should have told the
[__] Air Marshal yeah why didn't this
feces on your chair what are you talking
about yo is this this was I don't know
like six seven years ago maybe like an
eight you know those this professional
homeless people yeah and have a scan so
what is the scam okay the old scam 20
the scam Mike [__] heard about my jaw
drops but I had an idea and then I got
locked up and I got locked up in
November and Boulder uh-huh
now there was an article in Boulder and
Maine team before I got locked up I read
this thing that four out of five jails
like four out of five inmates surveyed
in Colorado said that Boulder County
Jail was the best jail in Colorado okay
so when you're homeless and Boulder the
reason why I was so good when I got
arrested in Boulder I couldn't believe
it I think that scene in Goodfellas
where you're cooking steaks and shed
clothes too close to it with no
gangsters close to it like he was one of
the most enjoyable months of my life
looking back up and everyone had like
red hair uh-huh everybody was laid back
the Apple killers in them of you in
general propagation but there were
levels okay
so I level on one you went to bed at
10:00 and you had regular channels two
four seven and [__] [__] [__] they
gave you teeny yeah not in your room but
you had you could wear your own clothes
family brought you clothes really you
can wear your own clothes you got to
wear [__] greens and they gave you
cigarettes what
gave you the roll ones OS I call those
pouches with the promo playlist yeah
really is really ought to give you those
yeah they'd feed you they give you
dental like the third day in Boulder
County Jail you go to the dentist
he's like you guys I have these you
ready to go Mike [__] you [__] you you
know you're getting [__] 850 an hour
you just graduated from the Academy
yourself I'm gonna let you drill in my
[__] right [__] you
yeah and that was [__] because the
day I got arrested the dad kidnapped
fella I went to the dentist that morning
ah I went for the dentist and they gave
me laughing gas and so my defense is
like tell them that you took the
laughing gas but I didn't do it I'm
stupid because somebody sent me an
article after I told the story but yeah
but yeah Boulder County Jail was voted
amongst [__] in vics the best jail in
the state so the scam was that people
would fly to Boulder in the hood in the
winter they would bust a boulder allow a
gag to Boulder and they would get
arrested - they would be in jail for the
winter right I guess was a scam they
knew exactly what to do yeah
that would keep them cuz then they go
and the guy was good you make bail okay
180 days see ya
so later it was [__] crazy how do I
like shot less dinners yes it was they
got showers because we cigarettes the
cable TV sounds great and it was if you
were nonviolent like me see my crime was
on the fence uh-huh so I can only get up
to a certain level but could do like me
so he put me up to level read or
something which in those days was
midnight cable TV Monday Night Football
they got pizza how that's very good
visually I can London I have a raise
right now don't let me take notice it
was a county jail yeah like a [__]
party in that County on Monday nights
they have like those frozen toasty no
pizzas yeah but even here in county jail
that's a [__] party with kool-aid with
no children event with light with the
sugar watered down like a [__]
yeah for Monday Night Football was
locked up when bo Jackson went through
[__] uh what's for it well then I
football yeah [__]
bo jail that's right I'm sorry well no
God I go yeah bo Jackson
the dude I did the Longest Yard way like
we were all living I'll care for the
Raiders Oh rain is against the Packer
yeah Brian Bosworth and he [__] ran
over mmm you know you've never seen
somebody black dudes jumping up and down
and bald and [__] and I was in Boulder
for a month
oh wow thanks oh by this first week I
was in level red talking [__] aha and
you're in there with other guys and they
tell you to shut your [__] mouth
okay because those are the same guys
that you go to court and they're like
well you said that you mugged them
you're like no you're in hold on that
dude you were sitting next to the cell
he's a cop
uh-huh and all these people in the Yaak
and I wouldn't say nothing that people
ask me questions you know they want to
see your paperwork you guys see my paper
bro you need to see my [__] paper it
was crazy
I was watching about the homeless people
I was watching lockup on Netflix and
they had this guy I forgot it was New
Jersey had a thousand eighty eight
arrests yeah and he was just an
alcoholic and meth abuser and they said
one time the shortest he was out once
was four hours
he was detoxing he didn't want to leave
so he sat in front of the intake door
until they arrested him and he liked it
a thousand arrests sometimes some people
once they're institutionalized the life
becomes too real life becomes too real I
was locked up for a short amount of time
and I gotta tell you something that
first month outside yeah was [__]
surreal that it's a weird transition the
first transition because I spent a month
in County uh everybody around me knew
the town Boulder is a big town but it's
a small town the address came out in the
papers my name came out of the papers
where I worked so people looked at me
different I tried to go back to the same
job in hilly we don't think so when I
firing you but we think she just took a
breather right so one of the managers
that took a job in long month and he
hired me and I was so cracked at that
kind of I could sell 12 to 15 cause just
being me right I went there for a month
I blanked guys really cause cracks huh I
was
I was probably looking at [__]
Chinese what do you think if you've done
head down like nine years and technology
change like what are you what do you
think happens when you do 20 years and
you go in in 1999 in 1919 come out 2010
and have probably wore finger cell
phones and that's crazy I want to think
of that like that that's got to be you
go insane yeah you know if somebody
showed me Google or some porn site or
something and I did 20 [__] years my
brain but blow up yeah guess what you
don't have to [__] go to the mall no
more for pants what are you talking
about what size you 32 34 come on let's
go on Amazon what's that much I can show
ya and I belong to Amazon when I signed
up for the special program I get 24 hour
delivery right and next day there's a
box that you draw with your clothes in
your toothpaste people couldn't handle
it and I can't take it I can barely and
I've lived through it you know that's
what the beauty is that that some
technology's a little too too much you
know yeah and it has destroyed certain
things you know if you read keep the
Richard's book he talks a lot about how
nobody makes live albums no more bread
they forgot mm-hmm they technologically
so they put so much technology into it
that they missed the whole [__] game
right you know did you see that article
and we I think I might've even talked
about it before about that restaurant
owner who looked at there a security
camera footage and were like they were
getting a lot of complaints about the
food and it used to be great nothing
changed and they found that people were
spending like an hour longer because
they were looking on the taking pictures
on their phone and the food was getting
cold yeah read that yeah yeah yeah it's
an old article two or three and get the
pictures taken the audio the pictures
taken in their fancy meal right yeah I
was just slow the whole [__] down yeah
and then I don't know if you saw but in
the New York Post this weekend there was
an article about how like the
Millennials are like the laziest
generation like they don't go out
anymore they don't really drink the
whole mathletics thing that you hate is
what they do and it was aquitted like
they spend less money on alcohol than
anything than ever before
they don't really binge on it that's
great what I was told there are
visionary [__] then this is what
you're saying yeah
lunch but you know what's Millennials
like what's that comedy they shared them
and they go out to comedy and they don't
drink and they don't stay out and
they're not drug addicts like we were
the other state of there's nothing wrong
with that right
that's what they're into right and you
know it's it's last week I went back
after the [__] show and I've talked
about this a thousand times and it
bothers the [__] out of a guy like me I
like Tommy I respect comedy Tommy gave
me my life Tommy took me out of a
[__] hole you know and come on how a
Ramos type of guy like yeah I saw how
rain misses work
I left my [__] ass off last night
guys I was in my room at 10:30 on my
couch with ice on my knees my wife was
in bed and I was watching an episode of
The Honeymooners that I've watched 500
times Fran
goodbye I started at 10:30 and by 10:45
I had to turn it off because I was
laughing and crying at the same time
Frank crying about that at one time I
would watch this in my mother's house
uh-huh I was a kid that would wrasses
and I pick up the phone and call you
right who has also seen this episode ten
times before and we sit there like two
[__] for a half-hour either saying the
lines like I was okay I'm going to [__]
you you would not and the other night
[__] I would know what Mike Norton shiny
and you would know what nightshirt shiny
you know it's a pick I mean that's how
much of a funny fact I wasn't that I was
hooked on Gleason Norton The Odd Couple
and then we had a lineup of death we had
the Benny Hill show at 10:30 yes we had
the honey movies The Odd Couple Sanford
and Son sir and the twilight zone well
here in high school that's murder that
bothers me a Sunday right there it's off
the hood that was murderers row but as a
comedy guy like I didn't know I was
going to be a comedian do you think I
[__] knew I want to do comedy I was
just a fan of it mm-hmm like I was
enamored with
like hi if I saw you I'm going to just
watch Sanford and Son tonight you go no
I break the whole episode down to yeah
the timing the words like I [__]
living for that [__] yeah
so last night there's a scene where it
opens up with Alice and talking to some
young girl the girl says is 14 if the
girls going roller skate and then the
guy's going to pick her up and you know
when a father to meet the guy so can the
graphic or up there so the girl leaves
Ralph comes over hard day's work and she
starts telling Ross that why don't they
go out and dance and go roller skate
right looks like what are you crazy in
something he starts yelling and
screaming yeah and then Norton comes
here by the way out she goes you know
Ralph or you're so icky and he licks and
he goes icky and also he's sitting in
Norton comes in and he looks at doing is
going Alice just call Mickey what is
Hickey mean and don't look so good
it must mean fact I busted eye right
there yeah then there's a [__] scene
that Ralph agree he Alice makes her feel
terrible and Ralph agrees to go out
dancing with her ah so he ki is going to
teach him how to dance
he puts the whole [__] suit on Ralph
with the jacket the Hat he's a beep you
know he's saying all those things I kiss
you're late I'm eating the potato yeah
24 could do and all this [__] and one
puts his song on the hucklebuck he's a
dance you should know and [__] noise
starts dancing Doug and there's a scene
where he just hits his hands shaking
let's just see if you can find it please
Lisa at what should I put in
honeymooners okay and hucklebuck there's
also a Jerky Boys prank phone call about
the hucklebuck where he called one of
the writers oh and like really [__]
with them how good was it a jerky boys I
love that you're on I loved it first I
came along today I'm using the
honeymooners I say along with him like
but yet I played it for six months
really my call I like that didn't walk
good before you all before you got I got
the first one we tell them about the
furniture up his ass he's what about wax
on his ball
get back where I said that [__] killed
me that was like 94 mm-hmm 95 somebody
sold us a CD in college and the guy goes
he goes uh because I feel bad telling
this to you gonna be sick of it in two
days and I've been listening for 20
years all right you're non-stop check
out the [__] hucklebuck look at
Norton I never seen the hugglebot let's
get this like didn't fold a damn for the
first time let me know it do Columbus
find that what do you think well I guess
it's all right you ain't exactly no
things dog daddy from goober never mind
that you know this is comedy 100 wanted
yeah yeah I got the night is going to be
a big night for Allyson me and I want to
dance correctly this is not [__]
small Peter across waiting it on
Broadway or something across one Irish
bar he would go and drink look at the
[__] record player is the hucklebuck
oh is it always good for me so you knew
who was gonna have the best lines yeah
yeah and you would work it out what's
going watch them watching this is pure
class guys
[Music]
well here we go wait wait wait do you
see this move right here watch them eat
- that is heat right there
Spanish people couldn't do that in 51
this is [__] these you surrender that
[__] yeah laughs I don't I can't do that
[Music]
let's gonna record listen to the music
just do what the lurk it says on that I
reckon then so you're gonna do get that
boob and be gay [__] I don't know just I
dunno I'm gonna pay off as well just
call me 101 dog and literally 300 pounds
look I got to stand the knowledge CBS
Studios in New York City are you [__]
kidding me
Aloha it's wrong [__] Saturday Night
Live
look this is say my life right what like
duck
Ryan that's easy just walk like you
always do there was three writers on the
show look at one looking a little here
we go here we go
[Music]
look at the time you got this fat [__]
look pure brilliance guy what are you
doing
Russian up on a little dance and that's
all you wanted me to be a dancer so I'm
just brushing up well what is it crazy
goddamn you deserve it
this is the next costume this is what
all of us cats well I got it I got it
I'm hip ready to go I'm dog
all right as all this because of what we
talked about last night yes it isn't I'm
taking you out you'd kill this I think
it's like one of the first shows was
like a tough broad huh well no like was
a really a tough broad character like
her she already had a character in mind
and she auditioned for it and the agent
called and they said she was too
good-looking for the role mm-hmm
so this chick got up at 6:00 in the
morning I have a photographer come over
and he took pictures of her she first
got up in the morning smoking a
cigarette with no makeup on they gave
the pictures to Jackie Gleason Jackie
Gleason those is the girl I want awesome
this is the girl that was in the office
yesterday he said she was too pretty
so she Sue's a bad [__] in a little
[__] way you know I'm saying so here
she is standing up against one of the
funniest TV actors in [__] history
right they only shot like 21 of these
episodes I mean they shot like
40-something but these these rare ones
every ran forever - I don't in New York
City
yeah on every night venerations also
listen people sit around like this is
what you do the cousins come over
Christmas and you want that crisp after
he that you know that time watching the
wooden soldiers that's what you've been
doing since she was six right like
that's what your holidays are about when
you live on the East Coast like he's
last night I was watch this no Mike how
many times have I seen this it's in so
many rap songs like the references and
it's like didn't Eddie Murphy have a
spoof overt or something today like it's
so [__] not it's it's a revelant when
you're seven this was on TV from the
time I was like eight and I kept it a
secret cuz I didn't like black and white
TV I didn't hate it
last generation just don't yeah I was
against black-and-white TV the only
black and white TV I liked was my uh
Dick Van Dyke okay I favorite Martians I
[__] love but I hate the Star Trek
okay you see them say them doctor goes
in color but our Trek was all of the
beginning of structure I said like why
okay
I dug The Twilight Zone hmm but you
didn't have the balls to tell people
when I would spend my summers with my
godmother Raoul husband and me would
stay up all night watch The Twilight
Zone
sheesh it was like a mission we'd say
happened he'd break him down to me and
we talked about how affected our lives
it was [__] breath but then I started
opening up my mind to black and white
television I am them and by the time I
was 10 I was addicted to the
honeymooners I was in Catholic school so
I could watch it during the week it came
on 11 o'clock ah that's what I hate
about Catholic school that took two
honeymooners out of me until he sat in
Sunday's and played a [__] rag was
right so I lose my [__] morning I
would come home and sadly they would
talk about that side Valentin Pharaoh
and and Johnson are yeah kids would be
talking about the [__] honeymooners
how funny ralpherz might be talking so
when I got in the Catholic school that's
the number one thing I did I got cable
TV in my room and once the honeymoon is
every night guys not even thinking of
being a comedian yeah studying
everything he did just loving it and
going to the basketball court the next
day and [__] live in the scenes kind
of it was still freshman Ian basketball
we would get on the number one bus from
North Bergen high school to downtown and
we do the whole a couple beginning and
we do the whole thing I'd be drowned but
the bus driver pull over and say guys
knock it off please
did it go over your head at that age I'm
just trying to think of myself a 10 and
I think that's go over my head no the
shows that went over my head those days
were like English shows I don't know
with like Mary Hartman me I don't know
what they're saying I'm not sure like
those type of shows of the head I liked
in those days my favorite shows were
like room 222 which you guys would never
remember the courtship of Eddie's father
ah which is a brilliant show The Waltons
was was a brilliant show and then when I
went to Catholic school you had a
schedule of what you watched every night
there was kind of a pseudo vote but the
vote was already in by lunchtime you
took your buddies and said tonight we're
not gonna watch [__] happy days when
the ones WWE and Louie would be the
[__] factor so we give Lee like candy
swing vote give them saying or we goalie
we protect you we would go [__] I don't
need you guys then we pay something a
dollar kicked me in the stomach and then
we go we want to be protected yeah okay
I'll pick yeah yeah yeah when last hand
in prison or Catholic school yes it's
funny because tonight we were watching
the news before we ate dinner and I'm a
World News Tonight [__] do it
since since 20 years what's that what
what station is that ABC ok that's my
favorite festival then tells you about
the world news now [__] locally and
the first 10 minutes used to be
interesting now it's politics every
[__] night the GOP in the POS yeah I
have no idea what the [__] they're
talking about so it's killed me right
but they get into tornadoes tonight they
had two female cops get beat up by a
dude then a Samaritan came over they
have goofy [__] stories yeah I got
what I was going to tell you so I that's
right
yeah I took more than I shut up but that
feels good just the same you know what's
that I'm not really high on this
marijuana right now
good yeah yeah while you're with family
know where to go with delivery Leila
where are we was in the Hotel California
before this and I really got in the mood
to the [__] the laid-back styling in
the California lifestyle such a crazy
[__] home
if I thought if I if I told you guys
that when I was listening to the sound
with my mother's liberal that I'd be
listening to the sound for he is [__]
later
I tell you you were crazy yeah I tell
you correct like somebody came up to me
they said listen 40 years from now you'd
only be listening to the sound are you
[__] crazy
I would hate this I need Bob out of this
ok you can't listen to it every day but
when you hear the album that it's
entirely you yeah
takes me back it's good safety back to
the living room and drinking [__]
sodas and jumping up and down like an
[__] and being stalled and then about
4:45 epic lonen and I put eyes into my
eyes and [__] and my mother would come
home would ask me stupid questions what
I do today how school yeah
by that point I've become a nun I just
locked myself in my bedroom - yeah she'd
say come down - better than I'd be sober
you guys have any relationship not like
the actual internship but with former
players so now I'm just starting to see
players that I grew up with as a kid
retire and start being like broadcasters
and it's weird and it's also I like it
watching them on TV because livecd like
a lot of the ESPN coverage they're just
analysts amanah I never saw it like
Marc's leras play or something like that
but if you do see people that you that
play when you were kidding you're like
oh yeah I like I just like seeing them
talk about it cuz it makes me remember
in 1984 I was three-quarters [__] I
was 21 years old later that's right
don't match village Colorado with a
[__] I was housing okay I'd be a
little late I'm lying to you guys maybe
86 all right it was 86 I'm living in
Boulder Colorado 24 [__] years old
and one day just came to Manson or some
day Charles Bronson's gonna die and some
day Julia service is a retired I'm gonna
be [__] cracked and I'm gonna be
[__] cracked because they were the
glue all those years when I was a kid
that I like Sabbath right like you know
I didn't take them musically because you
can always listen to the music but these
guys going to stop making movies another
said little army thing what you saying
don't have to say what you say LeBron
James has been in the NBA for 14 years
already
yeah he got caught in oh three can you
believe that they're already talking
about him like I thought I could die
having that cable for a while so I was
watching ESPN and they said like when he
rest and then when he needs to he'll
turn it on like he's already been
already talking about him like he's been
winding down I didn't realize this I
mean I hold this LeBron James now let me
check third and he was 18 when he
started so he's probably 32 pretty great
I'm not gonna do that kind of math you
look it up
you know I think a lot about you of
Mansoul Tron I think a lot about you man
down people to cousin
yes I'm around there and I 32 my campus
tour and yeah that time you were pushing
the white shirt with the black jacket I
don't even remember what I was wearing
but there's definitely Blazers in blazes
yeah and I was always a fan of comedy
and I just watched him one night you
went up there was maybe 18 people but in
your mind it was the garden right you
know you just want to get with a smile
on your face and I found lovely items
that wasn't right it was like a priest
up there fake priest for a while yeah
you keep talking about that I remember
that was I was a character somebody did
yeah I don't [__] yeah yeah actually
right but it's so weird I see you
knowing you're the transition in your
life I was that high ten years the
feature act right headliner limbo
yeah yeah headline sometimes yeah like
you have like speech and mostly yeah
sometimes they call you like on a
Tuesday are you available tomorrow and
tonight I'll be there
yeah no sale I know I can handle the job
yeah it's funny how you're in that limbo
and you're just waiting for that last
push it could be a movie it could be a
special it could be a [__] commercial
it could be anything
you know what it could be yeah sounds
like we're jinx I can be done know where
it could be it could be the podcast it's
in that limbo
I haven't I still remember having this
conversation with Stephen is easy with
you now yeah it's not your [__] mind
[__] because it's like turning 50 you
don't know when it's going to happen but
it's going to happen you know yeah you
know we get to a realm here where
everybody knows who you are casting
people know who you are right you just
need to find out when the projects
getting done so you get your foot -
don't go listen what if I played this
character I played this [__]
this way yeah and they got three guys
they got to pay fifteen million dollars
already and they were thinking of
another guy so that would make that
budget sixty million dollars but you
know what that guy or maybe that guy was
worth three million dollars that guy
wouldn't change the [__] dimension
you go in there with a different
perspective on the character Jane
Laura's done it there's a lotta
comedian's restaurant
and change the whole perspective of a
movie that's where you're at right now
here's right there you know you could be
put on that Chris Rock Tour anything
sure yeah and another possibility yeah
everything like I was in that position
for [__] years I still AM we are
waiting for the [__] boat bell to
ring correct like you waiting for your
ship to come in and rolls movies to get
made and you're like I could have played
that yeah I could have done this this
way have we shown a note about it I wish
I would've known about narcos I woulda
got our marcos and talked to means
Sharon banished game Frank [__] you I
would have definitely had a passport for
narcos honeymoon to Colombia I come back
90 pounds lighter yeah talking about
mean [__] yeah I was trying to you know
that the host who later went to play the
hostess Elliott Cruiser the one family
cousin the one that left with the
sister-in-law the chubby dude that was
an informer at first he he worked for
Pablo if I could work that [__]
roller yes Yeah right
you don't be able to of course who so I
know like I was in that position from
yeah I remember dog The Longest Yard
made me headlines for about ten weeks
ah but it's uh no ticket service gotcha
it was long as yard people right it was
no no no it was Adam sailor people uh
after they saw my act
they were very disgruntled frequently I
stopped trying to book you oh my god
let's hear it movie comes out there
anyway they say never the movie comes
out in May of 2005 and it's a great
Permian everybody's happy comes out to
number two of the weekend I lost to
Chris Rock's movie which Chris Rock was
in two movies at the same time yeah what
was number one what was number two and
he beat us by like maybe three or four
billions okay we were cracked like I was
cracked right like I wanted to talk some
[__] at the store yeah [__] have you
done and [__] yeah I'm gonna movie this
number one [__] you're right so what
okay so I believe that that happens the
movie comes out Memorial Day weekend
nothing happens that's what if not a
tinkle not even a [__] birthday card
nothing not even a [__] nothing by
August an edible arrangement by August
I'm scratching my head on mine I just
put on my jersey and walk around right
100 be an [__] my buddy would call me
no Comic Con come down put your shirt on
right and get $10 a picture I go dry out
a little bit more class to that [__] in
fact and one of those guys like all
right it didn't work out for me and one
day I got a call I don't Joey Diaz
whatever thought that I guess create
radio knew your uncle putting together a
long as yard show and we're going to fly
you out and put you up and give you a
couple of yard sticks and just do this
show at the comic strip in New York look
at the habit eyes on the radio the whole
[__] [__] mmm okay so was me Jesus
you guys know I got a great memory I
forget this whole thing like okay the
only thing I remember you know shall not
hello who was in the movie with me and
he showed up to watch me and we became
friends during the movie
solemn guy but here I have agreed I'm
steady my friends are in the audience
and who comes to see me but the guy from
the Warriors movie a movie yeah come on
that way yeah he's in The Longest Yard
okay and our trailers were right next to
each other yeah almost I learned from
him
mm-hmm there's something like when you
meet someone you go oh [__] yeah and
they're knocking out of the parties out
there that's why that dude was
oppositely Murphy that's why that dude
was phenomenal in the crawl right that's
why that dude every performance he's is
from the Warriors he's who he is yeah
and I watched what he did he always
trained karate with the same guy uh-huh
Oh Chinese guy in the village he was in
New York City he bought the [__]
redstone that he grew up in he's trained
Crimea frontier no no he was human you
know do forms and yeah [__] take okay
everybody thought he was crazy
ah I got where he was come from he was a
sweetheart
bro yeah I would tell you things while
you were acting the real actually New
World
that's funny cuz I love him in the
Warriors I love the Lord in the yes
don't that you know I tell the story he
had to worry is because a friend of his
told him can you cover for me to play oh
really
he went in there Walter Hill was in the
audience often in the [__] realm in
addition back when he first moved to New
York from Michigan he moved to the Bronx
in 68 yeah
there was no long had people those
peoples at times at my clothes at people
yeah and upstairs
they said that he'd be in his apartment
sleeper the guys would be banging bowels
outside going dirty air come out and
play
hey Rick that's where you got that yeah
yeah yeah sometimes in life you borrow
[__] it just comes up yeah right when
you need it yeah what I did on it
because Toronto is a major league war
jock mmm you're what you're like way to
leak either one chamber yeah yeah how
does that make love that greatest
stories of all time but there's a Cuban
dude this is a voodoo yeah the Voodoo
like a superstitious cable yeah what
seems got a jock yeah and the owner
comes in so we had our locker room scene
ah
I said I'm CUBAN let me do a Serrano did
that's why we were joking right yeah
yeah you learn from other people yeah
absolutely I learn a from him he was
always on time and I know he always knew
his lines he always came to pan with two
tanks on every scene really so he didn't
yeah he would tell you that when
Heidemann listen resonable gonna do this
[__] he gonna do it your way your way it
will do it for me and it would be
wonderful throw away that's awesome and
he would bang it you look at the holy
[__]
house he come at that role from that
direction man I knew I could never be
that good that was twenty years of
theater yes films opposite people and ya
know people and this is what he did
though he was [__] he loves it
yang told me one time I don't do TV for
you for me to tell you that's like I
don't do the road yeah I don't do TV
right that's where your major guinnesses
you
you do a couple shows you get residuals
to your [__] 38 yeah you get
residuals to [__] Tomorrowland when
you're 80 you've got a rescission
because somebody in China yeah order the
[__] paint TV or something so how you
don't lean in duty because I like it but
I recently saw them on some some things
look at all over TV is different I
recently saw my CW playing like a
[__] devil on one of those ships so
things are bad all over you nice
attention sometimes people think that
what I choose if you can say yeah TV is
like more sophisticated than movies
right now anyways and actors are like
more interested in doing TV a thing well
because the movie bit Wilson first off
this is easy to [__] let's cut it out
I'll cat the fire games are like the
beauty about that you do the math okay
that becomes a time you don't become
that much of a drawing more mmm and I'm
producer from CBS come see this is
listen man you can be a great cop on
this show starting to salary 17:5 you
should twelve episodes your first year
the show becomes a hit let you come back
you're at 22 starting a salary in 7511
37 five you come back you're 50g BOS an
episode okay then it goes into episode
century but if 60 mm you know those guys
I remember every time the episode plays
you get Jesus and when the epoch when
the series ends you get Diaz so a lot of
these guys are like yeah let me know TV
it's a security you see these people who
go from shop much money do you think the
chick from inside the house I mean sure
I have no idea I just left behind a
hundred mommy left my ass off on be
she's great she really is great yeah I
first time my gosh she washed out I
gotta be honest I reverse my decision
uh-huh yeah I can cracks me up and veep
now I watch it she cracks me a photo man
yet she still got it man and I watched
that move with you had a limitation in
other movies a home runs but I can't
stop watching it I love that [__]
girl who to little girl from sign that
live with the blue glasses that plays
the [__] congresswoman
to be what's-her-name Li you went to the
movie which he plays sister's scene
effect I thought I was watching the
movie of her where she stole her she
bought eggs
she bought eggs and get to use in the
movie I love Tina face right I couldn't
take my eyes off uh-huh
when people talk [__] on people like
this serious there's people I love don't
[__] with them right like I would make a
movie with Tom Cruise and peanut butter
of course I love Tom Cruise no doubt
about it
Scientology with me I look the other way
with Tom Cruise opera Hanna I'm a
hypocrite Mon I look the other way when
I see Tom Cruise in Collado listen if
you walk into the Scientology temple I
love you beautiful building a beautiful
building bro Scientology's in trouble
well it's not real
without real I don't put more money into
I don't know that was fake Facebook
stuff so I'm the one in Tennessee oh no
what happens in go let's read that code
you know I know they put the
[__] in G chem sacred
Scientology's in jail no fee in
Scientologists no yeah for you whatever
sign all the times I went in there and
use one of the cleanses so any one of
the pay they kept sniffing is against
his will only I got a cell phone they
call the cops the cops came and they
were livin on trailers with blankets
issues so they arrested this is
Tennessee this is in California with
rifle liberal-minded
oh yeah Scientology so now I read this
thing they honored that they want demand
Trump to go after Scientology from back
taxes ah like that's the new [__]
thing I read the other day like they
want Trump to go after Scientology for
back taxes too much money that day was
just crippled you think so yeah we just
there's no way there's too much money if
I had it don't they have billions and
what is that isn't that time Todd you
building up Burbank these are all $5
enjoy your take that you Hmong
angles why you think they put four
million dollars on that corner cells no
they're about the [__] cells yes but
they're about the we built this whole
they put they're about to retake this
whole [__] neighborhood you have to
be a Scientologist Natalie I hope you
find believe us you won't be able to
live in this neighborhood suitable nope
they're about to blow I told John but
over and being back I said John if I was
us start thinking about the future goes
why I got it you see how much money
Scientology spent on your own egos I saw
that I go for them to spend this mall
five million something's gonna happen up
here yeah and all that part of North
Hollywood that looks like it's 1951
still right
this looks like it's 1954 absolutely
yeah and it's not even attractive
anymore like the only thing I go up
there for is to go to martial art supply
store yeah because Bruce Lee used to go
with it so at least give them the first
shot like I got nothing to do sometimes
in same time I'll go up down a Tuesday
and walk around look at so it's yes all
right
kicking year right buy some and buy a
mouthpiece for ten for just walking
around like a mobile with your soy yeah
yeah I'll buy a shoelace thank you watch
your bag or something who's stopping you
yeah nod but the place is [__] legit
yeah well they're sometimes gene LeBell
is in there you know I don't take to
work you know I just may go look at the
Bruce Lee [__] I look at the pads I look
at the [__] you know and there's a
lot of mingling I mean in the store I've
never mingled in the sword listen you
know in my day off for a little bit I
grew up on black belt magazine and then
there'd be a section and it would be
hard the martial art supplies in the
city so during the week I go to [__]
karate and Saturdays me and eight little
karate gangsters that not smoke pot some
of them were Christians some of them
didn't curse we take a bus into the city
and we go hug the martial arts apply in
the middle of New York City in 1975 ah
ten eleven and become a week lie to our
mothers and tell the world oh karate
tournament abroad
now we go to the city and we [__] go
to the seventh floor and it was like
heavens when you were a kid right like
it was a warehouse floor we class and
everything was in class casings - really
cool how much is that 1099 gonna have to
come back and let the save for three
weeks and get the paper route
like we buy the iron palm technique like
we get the bag and get the juju juice
and we do the iron palm technique like
[__] because in those days I was a
movie that the guy would go like this
this palms would get red and then he's
[__] you up with the palm at that
session we go over there and buy like
geez we buy like headbands and the
things that you hold and punch that I
wouldn't and it's a pad and you beat him
till our knuckles would bleed she said
they will let it ruin lunatics though I
move it takes did what did your mom
think that leaders like terrible Khurana
you never want to meddle I went to
karate got every fall from the time I
got from the time I moved from the time
I was six the time I got head-to-head
with the lunchbox Oh
as soon as the stitches came out maybe
two weeks after that I was put in karate
and I started going like three days a
week and my behavior by my body so I
started put me in there five days a week
and I got kicked in the stomach one time
so hard by affected I knocked the air
out of me dog I didn't go to karate for
like two [__] days I was petrified
and then I said [__] I went back and
I learned how to kick and you know like
something woke me up yeah and I wanted
that I liked it guys there was a bunch
of geeks and we go in Saturdays and mop
the [__] tank you know what I wasn't
getting in trouble then yeah you'd wear
black D with a fist on the [__] thing
that said gold you and I'd be training
what black dudes is [__] and then we
moved to Jersey and I joined this other
place foo job by come foo but I couldn't
do all that stuff flying through the air
so I didn't really like it Marathi yeah
left front with the karate the
traditional karate so it was like good
route karate and I started going down
there and it went and those days guys
it started at four you stayed that those
seven eight o'clock at night because
your goal was to be 10 or 11 but to be
let into the 13 year old class and
that's where you got the [__] knocked
out of you but you got better quick once
you got that classing you're doing good
you do good in tournaments that were 11
year old so that's what we did we'd stay
there sweep the floors we thought the
master was real we bow and [__] I know
but that's all the time like you said
you went to these tournaments with
anyone did all stuff yeah we didn't your
mom ever sing like cool but he's going
all this time why isn't you anything and
he meant hallucinating no no no I used
to bring home trophies and I said okay
you know I was just thinking about my
little karate my favor whatever I
haven't had lunch it was from the last
karate 20 my 1 4 it was like a two-foot
trophy I won kata and that was a
February 19th 1979 I still remember that
trophy being in the middle of mantle I
was proud of it [__] had a few medals
and a few smaller trophies I got a
skateboarding trophy that I still got
the first-place vert Pax River Maryland
what's up was the summer I learned the
invert man I was unstoppable
you slept only two other people enter
the content still like the staple from
time to time from time to time it's been
a year like I got it on my resume as an
actor so if they like hit me up I got to
make a demo tape real quick and I'm
[__] dying falling on the ground lay
on this skateboard just to get like 30
seconds of footage I'll show you after
though I landed a shove it and a
kickflip in this footage no way and then
I went into the room the audition room
and I did 360s which I didn't even think
I could do but I just [__] went for
it
didn't get the job but at least it got
me back on the skateboard that's cool ok
moral to that story I can't even do a
cake soap with like those hand
skateboard well that's a lot harder than
actually doing a kickflip really well I
can't do with my fingers either ok no do
I know anyone that really can Joe the
audience misses you big time oh the
audience we drop a [__] about this show
at 10 o'clock at night
yeah at least you have to join escape
footing you know I never skateboard I
have that [__] from day one
thank you so I look at you it's
beautiful yeah I got a [__] audition
I wanna be around it's gonna be a home
of the life wheel jockey good
where's could be the one somebody and
prays no ha ha so somebody's like that
there's definitely THC and that uh candy
you gave me I don't think so
no I'm telling you you guys are ready to
reexamine the product I feel slightly
out of it that's what I gave it to you
for do you hear this song just hear the
song know what's on hooli you look at
Lisa I crack him funny son pulled that
masculine shoulder the [__] is going on
here I did that prank one time and I
can't he lost his mind that's funny
Danny be uncool whoa just posted a
picture of the kid his name is Craig
Krenzel when they were [__] high as
[__] my acid I mean we were burn it
right that's when acid would burn like I
would look at Lee and Lee would be
purple ah
were you scared Ali now we would like to
look at each other for a few but we
giggle because we're bubblers recitation
oh my god they say you know horrific
purple diverse thought it was three of
us it was meat cred to the rhythm the
skin Louie casting we know and we'll
[__] go to this movie I forget what
it's like a ping for we were on fire
right at that time I was a double-barrel
okay I was like uh I got I got like a I
used to get a sedan and on East
Stroudsburg I some time to time the one
guy would take me in the back room we go
listen when I'm about to give you don't
[__] with ezel he don't think people can
handle it dokyum of this okay can I go
how good is hit the gong go I told you
leave these guys were 24 ah if I was 16
he's gonna maybe if I'm exaggerating 23
I didn't ask questions they gave me a
great deal on acid though I would walk
in there with $400 and walk out of there
with a box of goodies
ah and they had the campus police on the
payroll
these kids were geniuses they said [__]
school we're going to make [__] [__]
in our basements right and they were
making black beauties
no no the black beauties ever bought
them by
the cynical black beauties sighs a
[__] off market and sell them to me
they will probably mine for a quarter
piece and someone to me for 50 cents a
piece I can get a dollar for those
things like these kids with geniuses ah
they knew listen we'll keep our prices
low but you buy only from lunch right
you show up every [__] Saturday and I
guess they did something they were
geniuses because every day of the week
they had different people coming at
different places so it would never go to
the same place the same time but it was
always on campus because they had campus
police right field or they were [__]
geniuses I forget what their names were
don't matter
they're probably happier that way but
from time to time Lee I would go then he
go
he called me uh Koko something he was a
white kid from [__] Brooklyn but I he
loved the whole Spanish culture and
that's how we attracted the other do was
just a white Jewish dude huh
and they were both like what have what's
the biggest thing you could be like a
chemistry major but they figured out how
to make lunes mm-hmm and they figured
out how to make this protects the acid
and they were cooking guys these guys
had nailed it and everywhere every week
you met them they always had something
different blonde arrested for way a sin
ah ha liquid acid they always had
something but every once in a while they
clean the other room and go listen I can
only give you 100 hits of this for
certain reason I'm gonna give you this
for $4 of peace you're looking at ten
and ends up in the hospital that I write
there it's like they would tell you if
they're not psychologically right
they're gonna be in a war on this [__]
don't get with this [__] you know Syd
Barrett oh and I would rip half the
piece I would take 15 years with
Colangelo brothers oh they would eat
that sheet in two days a chemical Angela
brothers finally
Steven those that himself in 82 of the
kids none of my acid god forbid okay
thank God did it come to me that weekend
but he was humbled I really put
are you asking what you don't know what
your vetting process I wasn't I was
oddly answered gave by that point
I swear to my mother's grave and I'll
get Timmy rusty : you know I was in high
school on Friday nights I had to be 16
st. Nikolai Neil had a big TV was a
sophomore by that point what oh my god
yeah I ain't an 18 year old Tom
hysterical he was write his own notes
with hello why were you absent yesterday
give me a note I whip one up in a minute
Angelo is the real deal yeah so it was
him his brother antenna and Colangelo
was a big kid but his brother was a
[__] pro bodybuilder okay he was
yoked and that man he was yoked on the
goods all the time then they had hell
with this other dude that was dangerous
- his name was Tara
he was just a ngerous and these guys I
swear on my mother's grave would buy a
hundred sheets acid a hundred hits a
hats on a sheet
oh and they don't camp on the Friday and
come back on Sunday all right and they
buy a hundred of 100 they buy a hundred
hits okay so three of them will
disappear into the woods on Friday and
they come back Sunday the acid was gone
baby sure then he they'd eat eat 3333
it's a so we know is Christ man and they
would burn like they would they would
tell me the stories with little blackout
and lose each other as [__] better call
the ambulance on top of helicopters but
years later they were getting high
somewhere the brother stabbed himself in
the stomach they live yeah on 11 hits
and after tonight you're gonna do that
do you so [__] believe that
Oh at that time I could do like 3 hits
ass I'll look at if you sing let's go oh
my god I don't know acid I've never done
this happen it's fun but I can't even
imagine driving to go get it like I only
want like a silencer you don't like like
it I don't like it that much to like go
like Woods Creek believe it should I've
given you yes I first want always taking
care you know I like the [__] of
what I'm giving you
I don't think I know but I [__] you
off because if I gave him I'm supposed
to give you
you wouldn't be sitting there normal you
just be getting out of the psych ward
and he was once again you know like the
[__] lieutenant in the Pink Panther
remember the Pink Panther drummer so
crazy he went to the psych ward for like
a [__] year and then he came out and
the Pink Panther would sneak up on him
from time to time to apologize to freak
out the [__] we'd actually what there's
nothing I would give it Lee when I was
doing acid I would take it at eight and
by eleven o'clock I just go into this
[__] haze he says PMR a.m. this is
Pierre okay and I wouldn't come back
into focus till about 1:00 1:30 mmm
and then I know who the [__] I am but
I'd still be tripping right like you
lose yourself for three hours late huh
like you call me the next day say where
do we go
you don't remember one to 7-eleven
laughing at the lady with the hole
inside look at the part I pulled up with
you did that happen over here we both
know is that a hallucination no but
that's the type of [__] that happens
yeah like we you want to walk over there
drive let's walk over there and then you
walk the 7-eleven it's real lights up
yeah it's like that scene and go what do
you what do you do with the eyes I'm
always worried about my eyes not you
just [__] don't make direct eye
contact make eye contact but very
briefly be shifting speech and
untrustable yeah Morgan we're paying
cash we're going to pay and then we got
to walk out of there and you know
there's people that live in those parks
waiting so you guys like you or me to be
walking by the people the cops go have
to go in that Park at night because they
got a lot of homeless crazy people
looking to get a bottle of beer just to
go that 7-eleven walk back to the office
Lee and then we go to the [__] diner
and order food and candy and we just
they're anxious and we laugh at the
waitress giving them all they ask us kid
I don't know last time I took out
re-what acid well yeah I went down to a
concert we were too cheap to buy the
tickets
yeah so we're going to a diner eat food
and we just stared at it what's that
fool everybody goes to the Dip sandwich
Philippe's yeah yeah with the Philippe's
yeah we did he usually decided there
like that we need to get safe to go home
yet
and we on the train back to LA and then
we got home as her movie was out but a
bounty hunt for this chick with Mickey
Rourke we watch that on the way down
that was a wrestler no that's what the
[__] wrestler he's not a bounty
hunter wrestler the [__] wrestling
it's a matter with you
you know it's matter with me I'm when
your pills man come on you're [__]
candy but I'm out of my mind
it's Monday that you buddy though I'm
sobering up around on the walkers yeah
you go the hell I like that a little bit
later let me get through this always you
still got the pink eye
come on that's okay no yeah this for you
fillet this is Mike Caputo saying
awesome what is that what does that do I
have no idea that's probably the cutoff
you got in in whatever way we this is 25
[__] fingers you should have that
right now this is what you should have a
right now I'm not gonna have it
this is for you there's a component I
wanna go right now
all right thank you yeah I'm sure you're
probably arrested you gonna be on the
island your plane's gonna go down you'll
be an island walking around like this
about you're the only survivor you gonna
wish you had a [__] daddies I'm
really great melon but here we go right
now I go for that 35 milligram elbow I
thought it was a little will regret this
man oh my goodness I'm happy you came on
tonight it's good meat working together
Milwaukee Detroit where we playing in
Michigan Michigan were at the magic hat
or something like that play in Ferndale
[__] Michigan and Wednesday
night were to turn a ballroom the Turner
hall Ballroom in Milwaukee one show
bubblebeam or out of that no more drum
we're gonna go eat Italian food this can
be great and the Italian neighborhood
maybe get a meatball sandwich I said I'm
gonna tell ya something you don't family
say at you bad [__]
we science let me buying a car and
selling I'm not buying cars co-signing
you know I'm not buying you girls are
good you might as well buy them today
what are you doing what are you doing
actually my my girls is he doing
she's my girls buying her first color
and I'm going what's your cosine is
cosine you buy the car she won't lead to
she has good credit you just bought a
car
he's cosign
it's fine everything we're fine is but
you are your co-signing for a car I'm
microfiber and car what are you doing
then I'm gone once I was going with her
be there oh you're negotiate this I
think this place is another one of those
no negotiating places but listen you
don't appreciate you're a Jew and yeah I
can bring him down the show up with five
yardsticks and some tell not to say a
[__] word they go ahead of the whole
[__] thing and you walk in there oh I
wanna buy this goddamn car I'd love to
see that I'm giving you a nickel over
the [__] price I'd love to see you do
that where you buy this car today you
start going here for seven hundred just
said five weeks until five yeah I'll do
five okay but hold on one second let me
talk to my wife in Spanish it
make-believe then you come back in and
going on my wife's two-month 650 she
so-called work on max no do it over
there for this price alright we're going
to show you the car is what about the
little dent in the hemp rocket will take
the car it is she could drive to Van
Nuys and fencing the [__] car gives a
[__] and two is going to kill the
[__] thing anyway we'll be back here
to enterprise it so what is you tomorrow
there I want you to say good I made out
of your Jewish listen over they haven't
get it memorized yeah you don't buy
nothing as easily all right
you always got to go in then you always
going to ask for something it's 2017
they making cars like they you know ask
for extra cup holders or something no no
no no no listen let me Friday lights
before we do this is my wife I love I'm
gonna marry we will move back to Mexico
before Trump bosal
and when technically your legs ago
listen to me I'm not giving you 11
[__] I can come I call my bank
where will banks don't sell cars we
shall cause I understand sir but this is
a business area say okay you cannot get
eleven five for that car come on all for
you ten five for the [__] car and you
start from dentally I can't do it for
ten five listen let me talk to my wife
if you go over the yellow in Spanish
maybe give her a back end and then come
back consult in the [__] do it again
it's the American wax used to be crying
or extract would you buy the car today
and you go yeah but you gotta give me
seven
he just said a nickel that is not
confusing now I said he has a 50
American dollars you're talking pesos
you look at my wife and your [__] are
you racially profiling let me call the
[__] Jew Jew Jewish OC Asian of
America and I'll get John [__] at ABC
News and see how fun it is then all
right all right all right I'll give you
750 don't call nobody ain't gonna call
nobody tomorrow man you got all that
right and you can wear forward we're
gonna have good because it's going to be
11 5 plus warranty Plus this Plus that
it's looking like it's going to be
probably at least I can someone get
these deals and then get the student one
week she well we're not sure the student
one might only be if you buy it so that
it just depends on what you decide to do
it's either the good lease dealer or but
it's not that it's not it's like 500 or
700 dollars usually which is nice look
at that good down payment buying the car
is very stressful and terrible thing
about buying the car today is why a lot
of people say selling cars is very hard
because people don't go in there and
they already know the prices right so
before you go in there research Li oh
yeah he's behind I hope you love all
this [__] no no but you love all this
[__] I don't know who the contact I wish
I can help you I only have one guy that
I know and if you like a car that if you
call me right we'll go over there
together and he'll cut the deal that
will make you a stand up if you want in
it okay I'm just you like something from
there if you like is Annette up because
you liked anything she wants to cheat
with deals you can get you a lot of the
automatic let's go for that little
American car because she needs a pope
now she likes Toyotas she likes Honda EU
Presidency so Vegas America college
Honda every Honda has a backup camera
now every Honda I'll give you the lowest
model its patent yeah to me okay so I
forget I have it as I go look at it the
trend test
yeah it became a world of a world that
yellow wine we can stop the [__] car
right you play long review
in the [__] parking spot like a
doctor yeah and when you start that
thing comes in handy is another [__] I
was gone all the time though I was like
in the front all sides
yeah so you have a major hit the actor
cooker we start getting animal yeah man
I got the @replies agent so get them on
the phone say look this is [__] mad
fool charge bunk a little brag and say I
want to start going on co-stars I'm like
I'm a convict
I'm out here I need [__] ma I need
fire coming at me from four different
directions I got the right cast I need a
couple this I need that energy that you
ever call people up and tell them [__]
it off their ass you have to get what
agency you would there's something
called elevate which actually is a lot
of comics there that you would know but
it's nothing forgive me but it's nothing
special
hmm I don't know what they're really
capable of well listen you want to have
a personal relationship with them but
you don't well I just [__] that out
dinner
yeah I gotta you got to go lunch with
them from time to time and bring you got
to always be in their eye
if you're doing a show make a fly off
editor so they're always there's ways to
[__] with them right you don't want to
go out and smack [__] ass out
cabinet [__] there's different ways to
get people involved if they don't
respond to it and you got to cut them
loose right and look for somebody else
because you you can't live in Lausanne
I'm gonna make a call Foley I got to
call a friend of mine in fact I'm
playing phone tag with commercials yeah
I'm talking with people no I don't the
money today in LA although money there
is is non-union tomorrow really
non-union going give you like a mother
oh my god thank you a second that's the
word on the street right now they just
pay a lot of money up front then right
yeah they let you know exactly what
they're going to pay you there's no
[__] monthly fees you're not going to
get a check of the man
yeah what they do is they go Lisa at
you're going to play a [__] Bob it's
going to run national and
internationally we're going to give you
17 five and go [__] yourself and one day
you're going to wake up and you'll get
postcards from [__] camera going this
thing's been playing ten times a day so
this is downside to it right and there's
for a while you feel violated
you're like these dudes are [__]
making rent on my [__] but how long does
it take to shoot at that hot commercial
three days and since it's line using
issue like an animal
they shoot like animals but you know
because a lot of work is not getting
that I guarantee the non-union work they
treat people a little better
you know I don't know I'm not in that
game but from speakings of different
people bumping into friends of mine from
ten years you know they were saying
auditions people like I'm thinking of
going non-new you're like there's a part
of the union saying that there comes a
time where you could go world it's
called something ah
it's called like world why the some [__]
which means that you work but it doesn't
go towards your pension okay so it's a
win-lose situation so if I come to your
regular stance on unit project you're
going to make 300 [__] thousand
dollars eleven once big enough to shoot
in Bulgaria okay alright I'm listening
bull you get really you get 150 after
ten episodes and 150 thousand I guess
you pay a little tax in Bulgaria but the
rest goes to you yeah I'm saying but
yeah if that show becomes Seinfeld in
Bulgaria that's it that's it but a guy
like you would do comedy shows in
Bulgaria right and charge 50 to 50 at
the door and get me to play the violin
automaticall but I'm ready for all this
to happen leave you ready you ready to
do your part
come on enjoy your only commercial
audition I've gotten the last year they
told me exactly what they were going to
pay me oh and what they wanted me to do
a number looking at it
that's [__] crazy that this is what
they do with the commercial editions or
commercial editions used to be like
shooting craps yeah you didn't know you
went to him because you had nothing to
do right you had nothing to do that that
it's called everybody end yeah thank you
everyone else guys I want to have a good
3:30 other Thursday gotta go and you're
gonna have in your bump into re sure
oh you bump a date due to the store team
baby yeah yeah upon release and I got
this and I got that you start saying
this guy goes that they call you for
this so sometimes by going to an
audition you bump into somebody who
gives you information about another job
yeah so in those days I would always go
to the front down like they would never
strenuous for me I would just wrap my
day around if it was 11 o'clock
where was the audition boom Marina del
Rey there's a pizza joint down there
that opens up at 11:15 not like you did
tough yeah make a little [__] dad now
I can't do that I don't get those type
of dishes right I get our dishes to go
to [__] Gower for the afternoon
that's what I want to do that's what I
want to [__] do inside our goals yeah
go to God dose the [__] ax for the
after love you come out of there to
[__] death traffic right there and
going the answer you want to [__] do
what I'm still fortune on getting
audition just as long they're gonna TV
tonight though you believe that [__] I
can't you're talented [__]
you're the honey [__] man this
is the first time ever it's so they
called me in like two months ago for
something else and I went in there and I
actually bent over to show them my ass
Manuel I had the room like I do when I
walked out around that this wildcard is
perfect for the show yeah you know
that's what they look at sometimes is
that crazy you are what you wanted to do
in that [__] room and they call it as
I was getting in the uber to leave town
I go you guys got to the time I get to
LAX to let me know what you want to do
it right I'll back a little bit
your roll go on your trip enjoy yourself
mmm when I came back I thought that's
going to be in the year 2019 they call
it a week later so but Baz is on their
cool one kid we know from the store the
young kid comes in there yeah so they
all put words and for me so you know
right out nice to be in town for 20
years I know Maz how [__] long yeah
just out all Marable I remember him late
90s at the at the Comedy Store and we
would say while he was on stage [__]
noise Jubilee my Zuber Victor sighs you
brought here going be [__] he been
doing that me be like the seventh minute
I walk by so he was on saying yes I
creep up the stands I set out and I wait
till he took a breath on stage like go
mines you're blaming my to blah hell so
he said dance hey hey you had like three
more but it's yeah and I'd busted out
against Maz Jobrani mazda bombing
hayward dance along and he never got mad
at me he was always always been funny
man since the first time I saw him he's
funny and warm hmm like I ever been late
night Sunday night stay with him getting
tanked yeah
like I was a menace on Sunday nights
Sunday nights have always forever won't
be my favorite [__] night a party
still no now what do I do
okay think we're coming home on Sunday
are you a lollipop on a set on a Sunday
yeah my kid that's as crazy as I share
you know but Sunday night seems to be a
thing but I grew up with a culture with
Sunday's and especially September was
football game you start early you start
early you start early so I came from
that culture in North Bergen for those
[__] on Sundays they should
start at 10:00 okay we're going to a
game this [__] star that night and
that's often about a few beers I'm
telling about if you make lumps a half a
lude
yes I'm doing and I'm talking about like
high school games don't know what games
I gonna see I was talking about go to
see the giant okay thank God okay you
guys have taken Coke to see a high
school game
don't suppose you like for I'm listen if
I know anything about my hometown
they're people who get high and go to
those [__] games yeah get that
ecstasy we're going to the volleyball
match crazy there's people who still
live in high school you know that in
every town sure yeah little Dame is
there there with the hat on talking
about 1984 how they made the tackle
against Kevin you're like oh my god
days the computers the movie come to
life yeah yeah yeah so know that Coach
that early morning Sunday culture we get
together at 12 and I won a class on
these tapping on the show and before you
leave the house you're like I'm just
going to go up have a few beers yeah
that's how [__] stupid but
intelligent but stupid or at the same
time right I got to leave it on a Sunday
I mean you'll see what's goin on I gotta
work tomorrow at 8:00 mmm I'll come home
like a 5 you got a second [__] beer
yeah you did like two or three vodka
[__] orange juice and two or three by
the third block and I'm like Worsley and
but if there's something somebody comes
up to you caption the hand and goes you
want to go half a half a gram absolutely
and you're like [__] yes twice RIT in 25
bucks in there I know you do little
bumps right trials and you sit and money
on business you have the best buzz of
your life you can pop you could go home
naturally going got the energy for Kevin
go home jerk-off twice and go to bed
come on and nobody knows nothing and
wake up like a foreigner more to drink
coffee and tip-top Magoo you're out
there with a bowl [__] honey loops
whatever the second outstanding citizen
but after about three four drinks
got a couple books and get here comes
Johnny dealer with a big bag he stated
Friday's aha so he's way behind this
kind of schedule so he points me in
savings for years so he bumps into and
also he starts giving you [__] taste
for that [__] voodoo and it's 4:00
4:30 afternoon
you said you can't talk yeah
what's that like what the [__] do you
think it's like right now y'all don't
know little guy what happens fun right
this is when you large or you're at the
bar
uh-huh you just got your eyes on the
screen and you don't want you and take
your eyes off the screen because life is
real I don't [__] coked up to the
gills
haha the coke is dripping down your
[__] throat you inhale it you try not
to let people know but it's 1984 the
whole bar is on right people trying to
be cool but at this point in society the
coke wasn't that speedy ah so we're
still people there were some people
chilling there were some people join but
not join join us we need your moves
yeah but your body does other
characteristics like your years ago or
you'll scratch your neck or something
like that just girls or you'll [__]
twitch every four minutes like you went
over to work in Iraq so so [__] up
you go to these bars and you you were in
there and after about an hour you felt
everybody's energy like your body
started like it became like a tuning
fork uh-huh because everybody around you
was on that [__] yeah I still remember
like it was clear as I stopped doing
that type of [__] where you would get
together on a Sunday and not get home
till Tuesday night you quit that like
you'd be a walk along town but hate
people well some of you got and make
beer runs yeah talking [__] telling
stories talking to chicks locking
yourself in the bathroom with Chiclets
and see if she'll friendly I mean yeah
it was just discussed so we're a few
things if she'll finger you whatever
either way it's horrible inevitable to
have room you're strangers it's 1984-85
that's my dad
what was work on Tuesday like were you
out of your mind you walked into there
like where were you
they're kidnapped by [__] Martians
and they translate to the black people
kidnapped I think job was Union I take
it no no listen at that time I would
burn through jobs like yeah you burn
through [__] dollar bills and I was
walking I would have a job every week
and in those days I just believed
through somebody your son bond you come
to me go you want to bartend sure it
would be that easy I'd [__] you over the
two-week I and Lee would come to me know
hey they need help over on my shipyard
16 bucks an hour y'all worked midnight
I'll take it right yeah there was up and
there was always you could always load
trucks okay
there was a PA and it was a Florida
Texas and they all paid 17 mm uh-huh you
went in there at 10 o'clock at night and
you worked in the morning and you take
back to the forum and a hundred bucks on
my painting and every time you take them
behind your bucks he give you another
shift that's the way it works you made
six for the night but you got a kick
back one it's like an agent so now when
you call to shape cuz you have a call I
like the clock I start calling a corner
angel there yeah this ain't Joe Diaz I'm
available to me you work here before
yeah when I don't know two weeks ago all
right come on down if I like you you
work tonight
ah you got to get your [__] call I
didn't have a call so that means I had
like Leon [__] holy right time
tonight of course be close by
I'll give you 10 bucks a gas truck now
we just get dropped off ah I would work
ten hours ago I don't know I'm getting
dragged condole God love me because nine
ten
somebody was going close to where I was
going right and they go see you're gonna
take a bus all the way out of your ride
right whoo-hoo Jesus Joseph and Larry
thank it was such a different [__]
game yes and I would always take the
midnight shift because they would I you
immediately right if you told him 4:00
to 12:00
everybody wanted for midnight also mate
before everybody want to leave before
but you walk in and go I don't want the
midnight ship are you serious
right you know one of the jobs I have as
well a hardware company who I'd worked
for before I can't remember the name
that they were big at that time and that
catch was you worked 10 hours a night
Monday through Thursday and Friday
you came in you punched in at 7:00 at
eight o'clock you punched out in your
window it was the craziest job I've ever
had and nobody would take that job I got
that joke that was a tight it was a
hardware company you first started as a
warehouse guy right and then half the
time you get promoted to different
department do you follow me so you get
the post or you get promoted to shipping
right so where's your posture is the
control freak well you can coming in for
one hour
on Friday because Friday like you're in
the week you each other a lot so I there
would be four bays
okay uh-huh and then before trucks when
you got there and me you Lee and Jerry
Rocha I'm all work together and we each
at a bay and we get there we go right
this what we're going to do I got three
trucks tonight in this Bay
you got three trucks we've got two
trucks and Jerry's got two trucks what
we're going to do is this we could work
alone we could work together and get out
of here two hours earlier um and still
get two hours overtime these guys are
slick mm-hmm and they would jump on
those [__] trucks and they would load
three quarters and then we'd have lunch
sweaty dirty yeah dust in your eyes
walking in the [__] then you come
back and we hit there at 7:00 and we had
a down them walk around let alone the
more than every night that's how we did
it that job and then on Friday nights
you just that's turn on Friday you don't
have four trucks ah that's it
and each truck head four things on it
like a curtain rod a bar of soap box of
nails and American shower curtain and
that was it and so you punch out at the
coordinating and nobody wanted
ja I hope that's alright because I
thought it was easy amazing yeah you're
out you still have Friday night right
you just go watch Miami right sideline
right
three out of ten thirty ready to run
when you're going through changes aren't
you two changes [__] Monday language
I am
look at you seated trained all weekend I
did on Monday night is in this Sunday
afternoon yeah we've done he's done no
Monday because he doesn't want to Train
he doesn't want to fight it up yeah why
don't you train today what happened we
go by the forty and by the mule take a
meal home we'll give you a little bit of
as week with no name my about it what's
the meal this [__] bond right here
that's the meal oh okay I don't buy a
meal you know where over there on the
blanket my lungs are already like
halfway to like transplant I'm like I'm
like oh [__] you're only 28 that means
you're gonna transplant we use 56 don't
I can happen as you can't run which you
don't run no more anyway so but I want
to have the option to let some man
there's no listen if you're not going to
run now you the other related that's not
true the last night around you total is
better run you had your chances you had
your chance in erotica you were supposed
to run you run
so dog last week I had a horrible
[__] experience oh yeah that couldn't
happen and this is [__] up because God
takes a guy something the hypnotism
worked okay that [__] that I've been
doing like tomorrow I'll go tell
attending tomorrow my last session if
that would have happened 10 years ago oh
my god I I sit there the last two days
last night I sat in the cabin I can't
believe I survived that Wednesday I wake
up [__] six good ones
no coffee water Listerine and toothbrush
I take a shower and I shoot down the
Hollywood whatever
I'm CLA I see my doctor he puts a finger
up my ass
does the he kg ha and then we're talkin
I give my doctor's note like the [__]
that I am I went to see the other doctor
two weeks ago I told that I know I'm
getting something wrong my right left
leg I know what it was and like minor
arthritis
and he x-ray he knows your writings and
minoritized does not really I could do
you know just take a leave and stuff and
lay off it change your habits that's
women do the elliptical Rhett get new
orthotics he's like do all this [__] is
paying the whole way so I go listen man
you gave me a test about a year ago to
see if I had rheumatoid arthritis and
then everyone done it he goes well give
me another blood testing so he gives it
to me like a doctor's note I put on my
wallet and ten years if I wouldn't think
of that no to the doctor I want to rip
that up like I did the first of all
right but give it to the doctor he was
gonna do a blood test anyway yeah I
figured they would just take the same
blood amount no my god thanks man and I
had to take an HIV test ah I just took
one year I don't have it no no no the
insurance company wanted me to take an
HIV okay I take the HIV test let me tell
you so I take the blood test and I have
lo a comb-over that's my [__] uh I'm on
iPod like right last Oh a como MA
ah I had a play like twice this time so
I knew they took our blood I didn't
faint yeah usually I start to squirm my
body yeah I was just thinking with my
eyeballs up toward the Halal ooh
whatever she taught me and [__] and I
saw I counted backwards and saw myself
walking down steps and every step I get
more relaxed that's all I thought about
in boob also I felt the needle go and
she put my arm up but when I went to get
up to get my cheese and [__] it sounds
like nine tubes of blood usually I would
have dropped to the [__] floor I said
if you contain it the hide even turning
colors yeah I just walked out okay
why did I come here and we do a podcast
I go home I sleep like a king I get up
Thursday morning I got to do a bunch of
shailu Jitsu I got a spot at The Comedy
Store I'm talking to my wife
there's a piece of toast she had a piece
of egg or one piece of toast okay it was
like a little piece of toast and I
picked it up I'm talking about the
weather or whatever the [__] would call
it luckily I had that now I have the
water cooler
at the same time I bit my toes ah I got
my robe on my robe is blue uh-huh I go I
said I look at there's no blood then
something happens I look at my finger in
it above my face okay oh Jesus Christ
now I'm still typing I'm writing but
every five or six minutes I got a white
blood out of my mouth on my robe okay my
robe is got chunks of red on it
by this time 10 years ago I would have
fainted right right so finally I put hot
water on that the [__] salt on it
yeah I put an ice cube too and it slows
it down but why she on the scream I go
to st. Joe's bubble bubble pop they
can't fix it they put some stuff on it
it's a bleeding temporary okay but every
three minutes I could taste the blood
yeah I'm checking it right okay I go
home boom we go to the [__] farmers
market what's that thing the food trucks
yeah we're running the baby the
pedophiles there I hadn't seen this was
last season he's there with the bubbles
which ones that Michael Jackson no this
bubble pedophile at North Hollywood
party has a bicycle and dogs I don't
know artyom ice high enough no benzio
again he only had like five kids so he
got pissed over me with the other side
of the park because what he's such a
pedophile researcher lose it local
pedophile yeah
so I'm sitting and talking about a wife
and playing with mercy I ate a chain
that me and my wife split a cheesesteak
yeah and well was he the cheese thing
bro
I look at the bread and it's [__] war
in and I'm like home like like the
French Dip Lee I Runkle yeah is like
friends if I run over I got a bunch of
napkins
this thing's on fire god that's how I go
home this thing's leaking bad and it's
Colin it's fashion guys it's coming now
my [__] chin I can feel it coagulate
on the inside of my lip I have a gap
over here the blood was becoming a tooth
of it like I had to take some toothbrush
and wash it and chunks of blood will
fall out
the top of the ceiling of my mouth
there was coagulation to blood I figured
let me eat some edibles yes I'll put
them [__] sleep apnea mask on chills
love the half of the sleep apnea will
blow on the tongue and I'll slow the
blood down and eventually your hardened
up into a swag right guys I lay on my
back on my back for maybe thirty minutes
I go to turn on my [__] left side and
I could feel the warmth on my face oh my
god finally
I'm trying to [__] just you don't
mean that I'm Johnny commando I gotta go
in Utah in the morning right this will
stop bleeding by the time I take the
fight my wife wakes me up this and show
you gurgling get up get up awesome I
don't like yeah you're getting a Jimi
Hendrix a ambulance you have to go to
the hospital oh my god guys I'm freaking
out
yeah I get up I call the light I take
the sleep apnoea basketball and three
ounces of blood oh yeah
although Robbie right here oh my God my
wife is freaking out Challenge boy
you're gonna bleed out you're gonna
bleed out I Drive myself to the hospital
the whole time I'm taking shits because
I'm drinking the blood diarrhea oh my
god I'm bleeding I got tissue they take
me back there and my blood pressure is
225 when we call 400 yard they give me a
blood pressure pill and the guy comes
back feels listen we can deliver
something bleeding so I 3:00 3:30 you're
from this little bleed to death here for
[__] four hours actually trying to
[__] him down he goes and I said [__]
you guys I thanked him I went oh my but
I'll ask you bothered I put the message
on I slept for three hours when I woke
up guys they had coagulated all over my
neck all the pillow it was have you
touched the pillow again what am I it
was a math guys off dead it was not good
the shining of it I put the hello to the
show and I spit and brushed my teeth for
maybe fifteen minutes general
it was awful guys it was terrible my
wife's begging me to go back to the
hospital
listen guys I'm not you know I'm not the
person I used to be I got four shells
I got an option I can milk this [__]
it's Utah I can't push the shells to
Sunday right right Miami you could push
the shows to Sunday yeah they're going
to show up on Sunday anyway and heels I
am but you can't push the Friday shows
and you taught us something my only
option was to call Joe Rogan's which
week it was yeah my only [__] option
right which didn't make sense at that
point even so I said [__] to the vegan
on the plan this guy's a great guy these
people driving from all over I got on
the plane with D'Agostino my bro didn't
look at my I hid from TSA the whole time
to see us at and say two [__] words
hmm and I could feel it coagulated in my
upper lip I was starting to come Fredo
yeah my upper lip was swelling his [__]
you're smart and I walked to secure him
with all that waste basket and sprinted
and it was just a bunch of blood I'm
going oh my god what am I gonna get
dizzy right I had paper towels all over
me bundles of tissue gauze it was all
over my face my lips at that point will
be read like the Joker yeah but it had
been bloody all night they were soaking
in blood just telling you guys this is
giving me [__] Agia I got on the plane
I'm sitting there guys and what's up
it's unbelievable that our flight I get
off the [__] plane I go to Urgent
Care the guy puts cocaine liquid on my
tongue really yeah a shrink something
I'm starting to think that I got hope of
the dullness dude
that's a good cliffhanger cocaine was
just introduced I I didn't know they had
like look who came to stop but it was
interesting because I had to a piece of
my tongue like I don't even know what it
was and if I had for a few years when I
first got that I wanted to just bite it
off for like cut off for the knife to do
it
doing that stick so I thought I could do
it and I told my dentist who did it for
me
he's a gave you did that you would have
went live in the emergency room right
because the tongue is like more like the
bloodiest if they can clot easy huh
there's a lot of blood in it a lot of
capillaries it just yeah I'm the reason
behind it but he's the laser and I was
trying to get Joe to go but he wasn't
open until 11:00 right oh my gosh just
thinking about it
I'll play the blood I don't know how you
dealt with all that blood that's crazy
and so did it stop it as soon as you put
that medicine on it
he put the liquid on it and it held a
little bit and then they put a piece of
silver on top right so I'm going to come
back to the story later yeah oh my god
to be continued for when I'm high on THC
I push yes hey make sure the face
mechanism right there it means I may be
able to get ceases over the pass the
[__] out on the story that's all [__]
up Irwin Jesus anyway I'm excited that
you go the more walking it can be fun
than I've been there in a long [__]
time I was there about two years ago I
always loved going to Milwaukee every
gig I played I [__] love Milwaukee
the first time I went to Milwaukee I
went there the weirdest thing to do
marketing University I could [__]
those days yeah and it was a horror show
uh-huh
but I wasn't yelling at that ball well
it feels a little bit better
[Music]
so everybody do it so when we get back
from New York
what did I give back from New York me
yeah she went me like I was back the
middle of April's back
Olea brochure what how do you like there
because it won like when I was growing
up I was always a dream to live in New
York how do you like it's really cool
man
it's easy to get around and there's
always something good to eat do or a way
no way no way subway come on yeah it's
not even a thing you can think about you
just do it's just part of it behave the
bus I'm thinking the bus before again I
think the audience just saw Frank
without Joey I think they come here for
Joey and I think we're really cooking
milking this shift on elbow to conclude
New York City is easy to get around with
and a great place to live I highly
recommend it it's amazing I feel sick
over sorry see I told that story so well
it actually smells like New York and
here
you